all right police in Galveston Texas are
apologizing after photos depicting a
controversial arrest technique ignited
outrage in the community check out these
images that show forced mounted police
officers who are both white leading a
handcuffed black man down the street
using what appears to be a rope many on
social media called the scene quote
disgusting and degrading in a statement
yesterday the Galveston Police
Department said this train technique is
considered a best practice in certain
scenarios but the police chief said the
officer showed poor judgment in this
instance he said the department has
changed its policy to prevent the use of
this method they also apologized for
causing the man quote unnecessary
embarrassment yes I don't know a million
might be a better word yeah yeah they
say it's the best practice but now
they're saying they're getting rid of it
right what cases and you cannot wait for
a patrol car to get there well the
imagery of it I think historically that
it's just it's such bad judgment context
matters yes